This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Back in January, Bloomberg News published a story quoting an obscure government official named Richard Trumpka Jr. He works with the Consumer Product Safety Commission, which regulates stuff like furniture and electronics and household appliances. Basically, the agency is supposed to make sure that the stuff we buy is safe and won't kill us or make us sick. The Bloomberg story talked about how a growing body of research shows that gas stoves are really bad for indoor air quality. They let off pollutants like nitrogen dioxide and carbon monoxide, and they've been linked to heart problems, cancer and asthma.
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。今年一月，彭博社发表了一篇报道，引用了一位名不见经传的政府官员理查德·特伦姆卡（Richard Trumpka Jr.）的话。他在消费品安全委员会工作，该委员会负责监管家具、电子产品和家用电器等物品。基本上，该机构应该确保我们购买的东西是安全的，不会致死或致病。彭博社的报道谈到，越来越多的研究表明，燃气灶对室内空气质量非常不利。它们会释放二氧化氮和一氧化碳等污染物，并且已经与心脏病、癌症和哮喘联系在一起。
And in this story, Trump has said that the government would look into it and maybe recommend some regulations on the appliance. Within days, the U.S. went bat shit crazy, and gas stoves were all over the news. They had become the subject of the latest skirmish in our seemingly never-ending culture war. The safety of in-home gas stoves is sparking a political battle in Washington. If the maniacs in the White House come for my stove, they can pry it from my cold dead hand.
在这篇报道中，特伦姆卡表示政府将对此进行调查，并可能对这种家电推荐一些监管措施。几天之内，美国就陷入了疯狂，燃气灶登上了各大新闻头条。它们成了我们看似没完没了的文化战争中最新冲突的主题。家用燃气灶的安全性正在华盛顿引发一场政治争夺。如果白宫的疯子们冲着我的炉灶来，他们只能从我冰冷僵硬的尸体上把它抢走。
I'm a cook. Nobody's gonna tell me I can't cook with gas. First of all, any good cook cooks with gas. Democrats are coming for your kitchen appliances. The federal government has no business telling American families how to cook their dinner. I was a little surprised by the level of emotion generated by this common household appliance, but it turns out there is a long and well documented history that explains our current moments. The natural gas industry has spent the past 100 years
我是一个厨师。没人能告诉我不能用燃气做饭。首先，任何好厨师都用燃气做饭。民主党人正冲着你们的厨房电器来。联邦政府无权告诉美国家庭如何做晚餐。我对这款常见家用电器所引发的情绪激烈程度感到有点意外，但事实证明，有一段漫长且有据可查的历史可以解释我们当前的时刻。天然气行业在过去100年里
selling Americans on the gas stove and trying to convince us that it is superior than the electric alternative, that it's classier, more functional, and that it just cooks our food better. Alongside that full-bore advertising campaign, the gas industry has waged another quieter battle, mostly beyond the view of the public. They've worked for decades to obscure and dispute what scientists increasingly know is true. Gas stoves are bad for our health, no matter how much we love that little click-click-click-whoosh sound. Which is admittedly a really great sound.
向美国人推销燃气灶，并试图让我们相信它比电炉更优越，它更有档次、功能更全，而且做出来的食物更好吃。除了这场全面铺开的广告宣传之外，天然气行业还发动了另一场更安静的战役，大多在公众视线之外。几十年来，他们一直致力于掩盖和否认科学家们日益了解的事实。燃气灶对我们的健康有害，不管我们有多么喜欢那个“咔哒-咔哒-咔哒-轰”的声音。尽管承认这确实是一个非常棒的声音。
Today we're going to look at those parallel histories and understand how we got to this place and why Americans have so many feelings about our stoves. Our guide today is Rebecca Lieber. She's a climate reporter who's worked for Mother Jones, Christ and Fox, and she's done a lot of work to unearth the history of the gas stove and what its popularity means for our health and the climate. Okay Rebecca, before we get into the history, I want to talk about the gas stove that you have in your apartment. I am curious. Do you have any strong feelings about it?
今天我们将回顾这些平行的历史，了解我们是如何走到这一步的，以及为什么美国人对我们的炉灶有这么多的情绪。我们今天的向导是丽贝卡·利伯（Rebecca Lieber）。她是一名气候记者，曾为《琼斯母亲》、基督与福克斯工作过，她做了大量工作来揭开燃气灶的历史，以及它的普及对我们的健康和气候意味着什么。好了，丽贝卡，在我们进入历史之前，我想谈谈你公寓里有的那个燃气灶。我很好奇。你对它有什么强烈的情感吗？
I am by no means a great cook. I am pretty casual about it, but I do think I bought into this myth around the gastov before I started reporting on this. I think I just had this vague sense that cooking with gas was just better. It's a fact. It's better than electric cooking. And now that I am reconsidering all of that, I realize how long I've been exposed to this imagery around expensive, huge ranges that are in these gleaming large homes. It's just this idea of a status symbol. And while I don't know if I have the same visceral reaction that some people do to using a flame when cooking, I realize I was influenced by this larger narrative around gas cooking. And it led me down this rabbit
我绝不是一个伟大的厨师。我对这方面挺随意的，但在我开始报道这个话题之前，我确实相信了围绕燃气灶的这个神话。我想我当时只是有一种模糊的感觉，认为用燃气做饭就是更好。这是一个事实。它比电器做饭更好。现在，当我重新考虑这一切时，我意识到自己暴露在这些昂贵、巨大的炉灶以及那些金碧辉煌的大房子里的形象周围有多长时间了。这只是一种身份象征的概念。虽然我不知道自己对做饭时使用明火是否有和其他人一样的本能反应，但我意识到我受到了围绕燃气烹饪的这个更大叙事的影响。这引导我走进了一个
hole of investigating why this is just taken as a matter of fact that gas cooking is superior. So, let's talk a little bit about that narrative and how it came to be. How far back can you trace the gas industries push for gas stoves? And also, why did they feel like they even had to advertise? Like, what were they up against? So this was the part I had the most fun doing because it took a lot of archival research going through newspapers in the last century to dig up ads showing how the industry was hiring
调查为什么燃气烹饪更优越被视为理所当然的兔子洞。那么，让我们来聊聊那个叙事以及它是如何形成的。你追溯到天然气行业对燃气灶的推动有多远？还有，为什么他们觉得甚至必须要打广告？比如说，他们面临着什么竞争？所以这是我做起来最好玩的部分，因为它需要大量的档案研究，翻阅上个世纪的报纸，去挖掘显示该行业如何雇佣
celebrities of the time to promote gas appliances. I'd say start looking at early 20th century. That's when gas was competing with wood fired appliances and coal fired appliances and electricity, so the gas industry had to find an edge and also market and convince consumers that this was the product to invest in. Okay, so this is a familiar story in a lot of ways. They're fighting for market share, and so of course they turn to advertising.
当时的明星来宣传燃气具的广告。我想说，从20世纪初开始看。那是燃气与燃木设备、燃煤设备和电力竞争的时候，所以天然气行业必须找到优势，还要进行营销并说服消费者这是值得投资的产品。好吧，从很多方面来看，这是一个熟悉的故事。他们在争夺市场份额，所以他们自然求助于广告。
And there's one example that you write about, which is the phrase cooking with gas, or now we're cooking with gas. Can you tell me about the origins of that phrase? Yeah, this is a great story because this originated from the gas industry itself. In the 1930s, a American gas association executive helped plant the story with the comedian Bob Hope's writers. So it became a part of his routine and really popularized this phrase that now we see everywhere. I was watching a TV show not long ago that had this in their writing. There is a very old Daffy Duck cartoon that also used now you're cooking with gas and it's supposed to mean now you're really on fire. So this is just one of those ways that we have really normalized gases as the superior product. This is just part of our everyday language, and it originated with a gas industry executive.
你写到的其中一个例子是“用燃气做饭”（cooking with gas）这个短语，或者现在我们说的“用燃气做饭真痛快”（now we're cooking with gas）。你能跟我讲讲这个短语的起源吗？是的，这是一个很棒的故事，因为这起源于天然气行业本身。在20世纪30年代，美国天然气协会的一位高管帮助将这个故事塞给了喜剧演员鲍勃·霍普（Bob Hope）的编剧。于是它成了他表演的一部分，并真正普及了这个我们现在随处可见的短语。不久前我看一个电视节目，他们的剧本里就用了这个。有一个非常古老的达菲鸭动画片也用过“now you're cooking with gas”，它的意思是现在你真的很火。所以这只是我们真正将燃气正常化为优质产品的方式之一。这只是我们日常语言的一部分，而它起源于天然气行业高管。
And so how did the industries advertising strategy change over time, you know, beyond the network looking with gas? Well, we see this early inception of influencer campaigns before there were really influencers. In the 1950s, the gas industry had this ad that featured actors as housewives touting their all-gas kitchen and convincing their husbands to buy them new appliances. Right away, did you know that this kitchen won an award from the woman's home companion? And really they thought of everything. I just love the convenience and modern styling of this building gas range.
那么，随着时间的推移，除了“用燃气做饭”这个网络之外，行业的广告策略是如何改变的呢？嗯，我们在真正有网红之前就看到了网红营销的早期萌芽。在20世纪50年代，天然气行业有这样一个广告，由演员饰演家庭主妇，吹捧他们全燃气厨房，并说服丈夫给他们买新家电。你马上就知道这个厨房赢得了《女性家庭伴侣》杂志的奖项了吗？他们真的是面面俱到。我太喜欢这个内置燃气灶的便利和现代造型了。
So there's plenty of examples like this throughout the decades, but one of my favorite examples was this 1980s era ad that I kind of stumbled along on YouTube. Just like the 1950s commercial starring housewives was very much of its era, this 1980s ad is this incredibly cringe-worthy rap about gas cooking. Cooking with gas. Cooking with gas. We all cook better when we're cooking with gas. Gas is so hot, it's not on when it's off. It's the only way to cook. That's what we were taught.
所以几十年里有大量这样的例子，但我最喜欢的例子之一是这个80年代的广告，我是偶然在YouTube上发现的。就像50年代由家庭主妇主演的商业广告极具那个时代的特色一样，这个80年代的广告是一首关于燃气烹饪的极其尴尬的说唱。用燃气做饭。用燃气做饭。当我们用燃气做饭时，我们都做得更好。燃气太热了，关上的时候它就不在。这是做饭的唯一方法。这就是我们被教导的。
I cook with gas because the cost is much less than electricity. Do you wanna take a gas? Well, it's three times less in the East or West So remember those figures when it's time to take a test Ugh! I cooked with gas cause broil and soap cream The flame consumes the smoke and grease you know what I mean And when I bake a pie to put on the sill
我用燃气做饭，因为成本比电低得多。你想猜一下吗？嗯，在东部或西部便宜三倍，所以在参加测试时记住这些数字。噢！我用燃气做饭是因为烧烤和肥皂霜。火焰消耗了烟雾和油脂，你知道我的意思。当我烤派放在窗台上
myself cleaning other andcavani spill, cooking with gas, cooking with gas. We all cook that up when we're cooking with... Oh my lord. Yeah, this is always a crowd favorite. Ha ha ha. It's incredible. And this really worked.
自洁烤箱和其他……洒出来，用燃气做饭，用燃气做饭。当我们用燃气……哦，天哪。是的，这总是观众最喜欢的。哈哈哈哈。这太不可思议了。这真的起作用了。
I mean, the outcome of this advertising was that, you know, gas stoves became pretty popular. The sales pitch has definitely worked. GAS went from practically non-existent to 30% during the 1970s. And in 2019, it grew to about 50% of single family American homes. It's even more common when you're talking about some of the most populous cities in states like California, New York, and Illinois, there we see well over 70% of homes using gas for cooking. But at the same time that the gas industry was pushing heavily
我的意思是，这种广告的结果是，你知道的，燃气灶变得相当受欢迎。销售策略绝对奏效了。在20世纪70年代，燃气的普及率从几乎不存在上升到30%。到2019年，它增长到约占美国家庭独立住宅的50%。如果说到加利福尼亚州、纽约州和伊利诺伊州等州一些人口最多的城市，它甚至更常见，在那里我们看到超过70%的家庭使用燃气做饭。但与此同时，天然气行业在大力推动
for people to adopt gas stoves, they were also realizing that there might be some problems with them, right? So there's this kind of parallel history of the industry learning about the health effects of stoves and fighting off the regulation. There were concerns from the very start. We see in, really, 1900s execs aware at least of carbon monoxide poisoning. But over the decades, as gas grew,
人们采用燃气灶的同时，他们也意识到这些炉灶可能存在一些问题，对吧？所以行业了解炉灶对健康的影响并抵制监管，这其中有一种平行的历史。从一开始就有担忧。实际上在20世纪初，高管们至少已经意识到了的一氧化碳中毒问题。但在随后的几十年里，随着天然气的发展，
there was a lot more scrutiny. So starting around the 1950s, 1960s, more scientific papers come out out looking at some of these specific pollutants we're talking about. By the 1970s and definitely the 1980s, it became very clear this was an area worth studying and that there was a lot of nuanced research to be done. A growing concern was that this could be causing asthma in children and the big question was how much? As it was becoming more and more clear that there was a problem here, did this trigger anything as to how to regulate it, how to make it safer?
审查也变得多得多。因此，从20世纪50年代、60年代左右开始，更多研究我们正在讨论的这些特定污染物的科学论文发表了。到了70年代，绝对到了80年代，很明显这是一个值得研究的领域，并且有许多细致的研究要做。人们越来越担心这可能会导致儿童哮喘，而最大的问题是程度有多重？随着这里的问题越来越明显，这是否引发了关于如何监管它、如何使之更安全的任何讨论？
Yeah, what's incredible is about 40 years ago, we had this deja vu debate over indoor air quality and gas. We had this deja vu debate over indoor air quality and gas. So in the 1980s, indoor air quality was just growing as a concern. Of course, there was more awareness around things like second-hand smoke, but gas was also getting more scrutiny. So Congress held some hearings around air quality, and gas was one of the topics that would come up. And consumer product safety commission started to look at this, of whether this was topics that would come up. And consumer product safety commission started to look at this,
是的，令人难以置信的是，大约40年前，我们就室内空气质量和燃气进行过这种似曾相识的辩论。我们对室内空气质量和燃气进行了这种似曾相识的辩论。所以在20世纪80年代，室内空气质量作为一个问题刚刚开始引起关注。当然，人们对二手烟之类的事情有了更多的认识，但燃气也受到了更多的审查。因此，国会围绕空气质量举行了一些听证会，燃气是出现的主题之一。消费品安全委员会开始研究这个问题，看这是否是出现的主题。消费品安全委员会开始研究这个问题，
of whether this was something that was worth regulating. So the consumer product safety commission asked the EPA about the effects of pollutants like nitrogen dioxide. And these agencies were in this dialogue around what are the health risks when it comes to gas cooking. And what's wild here is they were on the cusp of possible regulation, but the EPA pointed
看这是否是值得监管的事情。因此，消费品安全委员会向环保署（EPA）询问了二氧化氮等污染物的影响。这些机构就燃气烹饪方面的健康风险展开了对话。这里疯狂的是，他们正处于可能进行监管的边缘，但环保署指出
out that they had a lot of questions that remained, that they hoped scientists would answer in the future. And somehow in this back and forth, the whole thing was dropped. This also coincides with the Reagan administration that was not known for loving regulation in general. So in all this fuss, we just see this issue really received from popular discourse until the last few years when this became a hot topic again. From what I gather in your answer, is it just kind of fizzled out? Was there like, you know, some kind of shot to the heart when it came to the idea of regulation? It's a great question. I wish I had a complete answer here, but it was a mix. I think some of it
他们还有很多悬而未决的问题，希望科学家们能在未来给出答案。不知何故，在这次来来回回中，整件事就被搁置了。这也恰逢里根政府时期，该政府以总体上不喜欢监管而闻名。所以在所有这些大惊小怪中，我们只是看到这个问题真的退出了大众话语，直到最近几年这再次成为热门话题。从你的回答中我了解到，这只是不了了之了吗？在监管的想法方面，是不是遭到了某种致命打击？这是一个很好的问题。我希望我在这里能有一个完整的答案，但这是一个混合体。我认为其中一部分
fizzled out and dropped from public view. Another piece, though, was how the industry responded. You see a lot of parallels here between the gas industry and tobacco industry and how it delayed and disputed decades of scientific concerns around the risks of smoking. And the gas industry did something pretty similar to dispute the effects from these emissions, from gas cooking and just burning gas at large. And you see a lot of focus from them on the uncertainty and that there are questions that need to be answered. But even when we get those studies and we learn more of those answers, the industry has really pounced on that
不了了之并退出了公众视线。不过，另一部分是行业的反应方式。你在天然气行业和烟草行业之间看到了很多相似之处，它们如何推迟和否认几十年来关于吸烟风险的科学担忧。天然气行业做了非常类似的事情来否认这些排放物、燃气烹饪以及大量燃烧燃气的影响。你可以看到他们把很多重点放在不确定性以及需要回答的问题上。但即使我们得到了这些研究并了解到更多这些答案，该行业也真正利用了这一点
as the lack of regulation is proof that this is a product that's safe. The lack of regulation they fought is proof that it is safe. That I find this very maddening about science and policy and public health. You know, scientists do what scientists do, I find this very maddening about science and policy and public health. You know, scientists do what scientists do, which is like, if you ask them a question, they don't know the answer, they'll say,
作为缺乏监管是产品安全的证明。他们反对缺乏监管，以此作为安全的证明。我发现这对于科学、政策和公共卫生来说非常令人抓狂。你知道，科学家做科学家该做的事，我发现这对于科学、政策和公共卫生来说非常令人抓狂。你知道，科学家做科学家该做的事，那就是，如果你问他们一个他们不知道答案的问题，他们会说，
I don't know the answer. You know, whereas everyone else speaks with great authority. Yeah, I will say in the 1980s, a lot of these questions existed, but we've got in a special in the last few years, a lot more answers. And you are talking about asthma, lung problems, cardiovascular disease, and all of these problems can be a lot more pronounced in children who have small growing lungs,
我不知道答案。你知道的，而其他人说话都带着巨大的权威。是的，我要说的是，在20世纪80年代，许多这些问题都存在，但在过去的几年里，我们得到了更多的答案。你正在谈论的是哮喘、肺部问题、心血管疾病，所有这些问题在肺部正在发育的小孩子身上会更加明显，
and the elderly and people with some pre-existing conditions. There's also a lot of pollutants that are of concern that we're getting even more research on. So, one we've been talking about is nitrogen dioxide, which is linked to all of those health effects that I described, especially asthma. But there's also carbon monoxide that I think most people are familiar with.
还有老年人和一些有既往病史的人。还有许多我们正在获得更多研究的令人担忧的污染物。所以，我们一直在谈论的一个是二氧化氮，它与我描述的所有这些健康影响有关，尤其是哮喘。但也有大多数人都熟悉的一氧化碳。
There's benzene, which is a carcinogen, and there was a recent study that actually said that the benzene produced by the stove can exceed what you see in second-hand smoke. Wow. The other thing to mention is how that same pollution is contributing to poor air quality outside. These are the kinds of pollutants that interact and help to form ozone, which is also called smog.
还有苯，这是一种致癌物，最近有一项研究实际表明，炉灶产生的苯可以超过你在二手烟中看到的水平。哇。另一件要提的事情是，同样的污染是如何导致外部空气质量恶化的。这些是相互作用并有助于形成臭氧的污染物，臭氧也被称为雾霾。
This is methane that we're burning. Methane is a greenhouse gas that is a potent climate pollutant. So we're not just talking about air pollution here. We're talking about how gas appliances and gas infrastructure help contribute to global warming. One point the gas industry makes is that gas stoves are safe if you just use proper ventilation like a rain chute. What do you say to that idea? Ventilation is really important and it's true that any kind of cooking can produce something called
我们燃烧的是甲烷。甲烷是一种温室气体，是一种强效气候污染物。所以我们这里谈论的不仅仅是空气污染。我们讨论的是燃气具和燃气基础设施如何助力全球变暖。天然气行业提出的一个观点是，只要你使用适当的通风设备（如抽油烟机），燃气灶就是安全的。你对这个想法有什么看法？通风真的很重要，而且任何种类的烹饪都会产生一种叫做
particulate matter. So ventilation is important advice when it comes to any kind of cooking and especially when you're using the gastro, but there are some caveats here because this doesn't work as one size fits all advice. The gold standard for ventilation would be having a ducted range hood which basically takes that dirty air and vents it outside, but scientists have started on packing this question of how effective these hoods really are. And there's wide range. Some just don't have a powerful fan.
颗粒物的东西，这是真的。所以当涉及到任何种类的烹饪，特别是当你使用燃气灶时，通风是很重要的建议，但这里有一些警告，因为这并不能作为千篇一律的万灵药。通风的黄金标准是拥有一个带管道的抽油烟机，它基本上把那些脏空气抽走并排到室外，但科学家们已经开始剖析这些抽油烟机到底有多有效的问题。这有很大的范围。有些只是风扇不够强大。
The filter might be dirty. Some people also just have user error where they aren't turning it on when they cook. Lots of homes don't even have these hoods. I don't. So instead, I have to open a window to try to get some air circulation in my home. So it's unfortunately not as easy as just saying everyone ventilate because not everyone has access.
过滤网可能很脏。有些人还会有人为失误，也就是做饭时没有打开它。很多家里甚至没有这些抽油烟机。我家里就没有。所以相反，我必须打开窗户，试图让家里的空气流通。所以不幸的是，这并不像说“每个人都要通风”那么容易，因为不是每个人都有条件。
And we don't even have great data on this. Ventilation is important and it can cut the risk, but it doesn't work for everyone. So these federal agencies have been slow to regulate, but we are starting to see some mispalities take some action. Can you talk about some of the regulations that we've started to see over the past few years when it comes to gas stoves? Yeah, this issue really has taken off on a local level. Cooking with gas could become a thing of the past. 13 cities in one county in California have enacted new zoning codes, encouraging or requiring all electric for new construction.
我们甚至没有关于这方面的很好数据。通风很重要，它可以降低风险，但它并不适用于所有人。因此，这些联邦机构在监管方面行动迟缓，但我们开始看到一些市级地方采取了一些行动。你能谈谈过去几年我们在燃气灶方面开始看到的一些监管吗？是的，这个问题在地方层面上确实已经腾飞了。用燃气做饭可能成为过去式。加利福尼亚州一个县的13个城市已经颁布了新的区划法，鼓励或要求新建建筑全部使用电力。
That means no natural gas lines to new homes and apartments. The number is over 100 municipalities now that have taken some kind of action to phase out gas in their new construction. So this is spread far beyond California. There are cities in Washington State, Oregon, Massachusetts that have all taken action around gas. And we're actually seeing the snowball because now states are taking action. New York became the first state in the country to phase out gas in new construction. And California has been looking at this from the air quality perspective. Illinois has had an interesting bill in the works
这意味着新住宅和公寓没有天然气管道。现在有超过100个城市采取了某种行动，在新建建筑中逐步淘汰燃气。所以这已经远远传播出了加利福尼亚州。华盛顿州、俄勒冈州、马萨诸塞州的城市都围绕燃气采取了行动。我们实际上看到了滚雪球效应，因为现在各州都在采取行动。纽约州成为全国第一个在新建建筑中淘汰燃气的州。加利福尼亚州一直在从空气质量的角度来看待这个问题。伊利诺伊州正在酝酿一项有趣的法案，
where they would have manufacturers label gas stoves with some kind of danger warning. So there's been a lot of interesting approaches here that are all really fresh and new and ongoing. So I think when we revisit this in just a few months, we would see a very different landscape than even now. And so what is the argument for the regulation? What are they centering on? Are they centering
他们将要求制造商在燃气灶上贴上某种危险警告标签。所以这里有很多有趣的方法，它们都非常新鲜、崭新且正在进行中。因此，我认为当我们在短短几个月内重新审视这一点时，我们会看到一个与现在非常不同的风景。那么，监管的论点是什么？他们聚焦于
around indoor air quality, or are they centering around climate change and non-reliance on fossil fuels? What is the center of the argument when it comes to regulation? Yeah, this is a great distinction because there's a couple parallel tracks. A lot of the regulation we're seeing is looking at this from a climate perspective saying, we need to phase out a big source of our climate pollution and that would entail stop building new pipelines to our buildings.
室内空气质量，还是聚焦于气候变化和不对化石燃料的依赖？当谈到监管时，辩论的核心是什么？是的，这是一个很好的区别，因为有几条平行的轨道。我们看到的许多监管都是从气候的角度来看待这一问题的，认为我们需要逐步淘汰我们气候污染的一个大来源，这将需要停止向我们的建筑物修建新的管道。
So New York buildings are the biggest source of their climate pollution. So this is significant. And by phasing out gas and new construction, we start to make that transition. But there's also this parallel track where we're talking about health concerns and air quality. And that has been moving a lot more slowly. And California has looked at this question. Some states are starting to look at this, but when it comes to regulation, that's not as far along as when we're looking at this from a climate perspective. And what has been the gas industry's response this time around,
所以纽约的建筑物是他们气候污染的最大来源。所以这意义重大。通过在新建建筑中逐步淘汰燃气，我们开始进行这种转型。但还有一条平行的轨道，我们讨论的是健康问题和空气质量。这进展要慢得多。加利福尼亚州一直在研究这个问题。一些州开始研究这个问题，但当谈到监管时，它还没有从气候角度来看待时那么超前。这一次天然气行业的反应是什么，
to some more heightened regulation on the more local level? So the gas industry has fought this pretty hard at the local level. They've launched these anti-electrification campaigns throughout the country, bringing really deep resources to pretty local fights. In California, there were examples of the industry sending out robot techs, warning that their gas stoves were going to be ripped out, which was untrue. One example that emerged in my reporting was a PR agency that went on next door to post and warn locals that their gastos were being taken away to tell them to go protest.
对于地方层面更严格的监管？因此，天然气行业在地方层面上进行了相当激烈的斗争。他们在全国各地发起了这些反电气化运动，将非常深厚的资源投入到相当地方化的斗争中。在加利福尼亚州，有该行业发送机器人电话的例子，警告说他们的燃气灶将被拆除，这是不真实的。我在报道中发现的一个例子是一家公关公司在邻里社交应用Nextdoor上发帖，警告当地居民他们的燃气灶将被拿走，并告诉他们去抗议。
And we're seeing versions of this fight throughout the country. But this is also escalating where we see at the state level, a lot of Republican states have passed legislation blocking cities and municipalities from banning gas appliances in their new construction. So we're seeing this fight get bigger and bigger. And we're going to get into the federal fight because a few months ago, this just exploded on a national stage too. Yeah.
我们在全国各地都看到了这场斗争的各种版本。但这也正在升级，我们在州一级看到，许多共和党州通过了立法，阻止城市和市镇在其新建建筑中禁止燃气具。所以我们看到这场斗争越来越大。我们要进入联邦层面的斗争，因为几个月前，这在国家舞台上也爆发了。是的。
Okay, let's talk a little bit about this explosion on the national stage. The political valence of this is kind of fascinating to me, you know, about what side you're on. And I guess if it comes to regulation versus non-regulation, that sort of goes along traditional lines. But when it comes to like people who have gas stoves versus if you have electric stoves,
好吧，让我们来谈谈这场在国家舞台上的爆发。它的政治含义对我来说相当迷人，你知道的，关于你站在哪一边。我想如果是监管与非监管之争，这大体上符合传统路线。但当谈到拥有燃气灶的人与拥有电炉的人相比时，
you know, I grew up in the rural south, there was no gas stoves at all when I lived in rich parts of the country. You know, cities and stuff they had. Gas stoves, galore, are you surprised about this as a part of the cultural war or does this just make sense to you? It makes a lot of sense, I think, just because I've reported on this for a few years now that I know from my reporting that when I first raised these ideas and scientific reports around air quality concerns, there was such a visceral reaction from people who either
你知道，我在农村南方长大，当我住在该国的富裕地区时，根本没有燃气灶。你知道，城市之类的有各种各样的燃气灶。作为文化战争的一部分，你对此感到惊讶吗？还是这对手头的事情对你来说理所当然？这很有意义，我想，仅仅因为我已经报道了几年，我知道从我的报道中，当我第一次提出这些关于空气质量关切的想法和科学报告时，那些要么
ran to the defense of the stove or they were deeply concerned and ready to rip it out of their home. So I know that this does touch and nerve for a lot of people. And for good reason, you're talking about an intimate environment in your kitchen and your own health. I was surprised by the timing of this debate because this really blew up more of a fear of regulation than actual regulation.
跑去捍卫炉灶，要么深感担忧并准备把它从家里拆除的人，产生了如此强烈的本能反应。所以我知道这确实触动了很多人的神经。而且有充分的理由，你谈论的是你厨房里的私密环境和你自己的健康。我对这场辩论的时机感到惊讶，因为这实际上更多地爆发了对监管的恐惧，而不是真正的监管。
And it ties into this political culture war because what we've seen is that some of the people running to the defense of the stove just don't have gas stoves. So some of my favorite examples like Florida, you saw Governor Ron DeSantis defend the gas stove. If we're doing it, I just want to make it clear to everybody. You know, when we say don't tread on Florida or let us alone,
这与这种政治文化战争息息相关，因为我们所看到的是，一些跑去捍卫炉灶的人根本就没有燃气灶。所以我最喜欢的一些例子，比如佛罗里达州，你看到州长罗恩·德桑蒂斯（Ron DeSantis）为燃气灶辩护。如果我们这样做，我只想向所有人明确这一点。你知道，当我们说“别踩佛罗里达”或“别管我们”时，
we mean that, including on your gas stoves. You're not taking our gas stoves away from us. That is your choice. And I know many people who cook a lot do not want to part with their gas stoves. And so we're going to stand up for that. You know, this is like, in Florida, gas cooking is only 8% of households, so quite small. So there is this blue red divide here.
我们是认真的，包括在你的燃气灶上。你们不会把我们的燃气灶从我们身边夺走。那是你的选择。而且我认识很多经常做饭的人，他们不想和他们的燃气灶分开。所以我们要站出来维护这一点。你知道，这就像，在佛罗里达州，燃气做饭只占家庭的8%，相当小。所以这里存在一条蓝红分界线。
Blue are parts of the country, have a lot more gas. So we're talking about California, New York, Illinois, and Massachusetts are really big gas states. And those are also states that are reliably blue and have a population that is deeply concerned about climate change. And you have political leaders who are interested in regulation and interested in moving forward on climate change.
蓝色是该国的某些地区，有更多的燃气。所以我们谈论的是加利福尼亚州、纽约州、伊利诺伊州和马萨诸塞州，它们是真正的燃气大州。这些州也是可靠的蓝色州，并且拥有非常关心气候变化的人口。而且你有对监管感兴趣、对推进气候变化感兴趣的政治领袖。
So it turns out this is pretty bad for the natural gas industry that this has become a culture war because the demographics don't really work out in its favor. If blue states turn their back on gas. I feel like a lot of the people are fighting because a stove is, it's going to be intimate in the kitchen. You cook with it, you use it in a certain way, you use it to make food. But like if you wrote an article about, I don't know, like that there's a possible ban on your water heater not getting gas versus being electric, like nobody would care.
所以事实证明，这对天然气行业来说非常糟糕，因为这演变成了一场文化战争，因为人口统计数据对它并不有利。如果蓝色州背弃燃气。我觉得很多人在抗争，因为炉灶是，它将是厨房里私密的东西。你用它做饭，你以某种方式使用它，你用它来做食物。但如果你写了一篇文章，比如说，关于你的热水器可能被禁而无法使用燃气只能用电，根本没人会在乎。
Does that seem true to you? Yeah, that's a great point because water heaters aren't innocent here. They do also cause problems. And when we're talking about gas cooking, I'm also talking about a lot of other gas appliances that have many of the same problems. But yeah, something like a water heater,
这听起来是真的吗？是的，这是一个很好的观点，因为热水器在这里并不无辜。它们确实也会引起问题。当我们谈论燃气烹饪时，我也在谈论许多其他具有许多相同问题的燃气具。但是的，像热水器这样的东西，
it's so different from the gas stove because it's kind of hidden. Like you're not interacting with that. You, I think it's actually, if it's working as a should, you shouldn't ever think about it. And the gas stove, though, is something you're using every day, or however often you cook, and it's something you're interacting with. Cooking has this emotional resonance, so it just hits very differently than a water heater.
它与燃气灶非常不同，因为它是某种程度上隐藏的。就像你没有与之互动一样。你，我认为实际上，如果它正常工作，你根本不应该想到它。然而，燃气灶是你每天都在使用或经常做饭时使用的东西，它是你与之互动的东西。烹饪具有这种情感共鸣，所以它的感受与热水器非常不同。
But the gas industry also recognizes that, And that's why we see these influencer campaigns throughout the years, because it knows the public has an emotional attachment to the stove. But it doesn't have that attachment to a water heater. And it's using it. It's using it as this wedge to drive people who might otherwise be all for climate action to object to electrification, because they don't want to lose that stove.
但天然气行业也意识到了这一点，这就是为什么我们看到这些年来这些网红营销的原因，因为它知道公众对炉灶有情感依恋。但它对热水器没有这种依恋。它正在利用这一点。它正在利用这一点作为楔子，将那些本来可能完全赞成气候行动的人推向反对电气化的对立面，因为他们不想失去那个炉灶。
So it's this important emotional issue for both sides. Coming up after the break, we talk more with Rebecca Lieber about the wider fight for electrification, why it's a powerful climate solution and why it's hard for consumers to change from gas to electric. I'm back with Rebecca Lieber. Rebecca, I want to ask about electrification, because ultimately, to lower carbon emissions,
所以这对双方来说都是一个重要的情感问题。中场休息后，我们将与丽贝卡·利伯更多地讨论更广泛的电气化之争，为什么它是一个强大的气候解决方案，以及为什么消费者很难从燃气转向电力。我又和丽贝卡·利伯在一起了。丽贝卡，我想问关于电气化的问题，因为归根结底，为了降低碳排放，
we have to make this switch away from combusted fossil fuels and towards electricity that runs on cleaner energy sources like wind and solar. And this gets tricky because gas is part of our infrastructure. Like once it's piped into your house, it is in your house. So could you talk about some of the hurdles that people face when it comes to swapping out their gas stoves for electric ones? So when we're talking about electric cooking,
我们必须从燃烧化石燃料转向由风能和太阳能等更清洁能源驱动的电力。这变得很棘手，因为燃气是我们基础设施的一部分。就像一旦它通过管道输送到你的家里，它就在你家里一样。所以你能谈谈人们在将燃气灶换成电炉时所面临的一些障碍吗？因此，当我们谈论电磁烹饪时，
the modern equivalent is induction. It's not the coils that were common decades ago that no one really likes. But induction works a little differently. It is heating the pan directly, so the surface doesn't actually get hot and A lot of people who have transitioned to induction love it and there's advantages to it and some disadvantages if you're comparing it one to one to gas The learning curve to induction is not that big I've talked to plenty of people who have installed induction in their kitchens and they love it. It heats water super fast and they don't have to worry about burning themselves.
现代的替代品是电磁炉（induction）。它不是几十年前很常见、没人真正喜欢的加热盘。但电磁炉的工作原理有点不同。它是直接加热锅，所以表面实际上不会变热。许多转向电磁炉的人都很喜欢它，它有优势，如果你把它与燃气进行一对一的比较，也有一些劣势。适应电磁炉的学习曲线并不是那么大。我跟很多在厨房里安装了电磁炉的人聊过，他们都很喜欢它。它烧水超级快，而且他们不用担心烫伤自己。
The bigger problems when it comes to transitioning to electric cooking, it's the infrastructure challenge because depending on your home, you might have to change your circuit breaker. You might have to deal with a condo association that has certain restrictions on renovations. You might be dealing with all these different kinds of challenges, which is why changing the home is such a complicated area because it's such an individual circumstance. I do think this is going to get easier over the next few years. Part of that is because there are new tax breaks and incentives through the Inflation Reduction Act past last year that will help to bring down the cost of some of these home renovations. One other thing just to mention is it doesn't always require a huge
当涉及到过渡到电气烹饪时，更大的问题是基础设施的挑战，因为根据你的房屋情况，你可能需要更换断路器。你可能不得不处理对装修有某些限制的业主协会。你可能正在处理所有这些不同类型的挑战，这就是为什么改造房屋是一个如此复杂的领域，因为它是如此具体的情况。我确实认为这在未来几年会变得更容易。部分原因是去年通过的《降低通货膨胀法案》带来了新的减税和激励措施，这将有助于降低其中一些房屋装修的成本。还有一件事要提的是，把你的厨房改装成更多电器的厨房并不总是需要大动干戈的
renovation to change your kitchen to more electric appliances. So I mentioned I'm a renter and even using my toaster oven, I'm plugging that in instead of using my oven. That's something I do as an alternative. And for renters especially a solution could be buying an induction plug-in stove top. You just kind of put it on top of your stove and plug it into the wall and it works kind of like a hot plate. That's another Renter Friendly solution. Just a paint a picture that this can have a diverse array of solutions. I mean, what is interesting to me is that in a way the gas industry is completely right to be fearful because there are lots of patches and solutions to provide electrification. But if a gas pipe isn't
装修。所以我提到我是一个租房者，甚至在使用我的烤面包机烤箱时，我是在插上电源使用它，而不是使用我的烤箱。这是我作为替代方案所做的事情。特别是对于租房者来说，一个解决方案可能是购买一个插电式电磁炉灶台。你只需把它放在炉灶上面，插进墙上的插座，它的工作原理有点像电热板。这是另一个适合租房者的解决方案。只是为了描绘一幅这可以有多种多样解决方案的画面。我的意思是，有趣的是，在某种程度上，天然气行业害怕是完全正确的，因为有很多修补和解决方案来提供电气化。但如果没有天然气管道
brought into a building, it's the end of the game for them. Yeah, the new construction is really important because if we're banning gas and new construction, that signals that this is an industry on the decline. It's very important for the gas industry that it doesn't go the way of coal, where we consider this a fuel of the past. But if gas is blocked in new construction, it's signaling exactly that. That this is an industry that's shrinking with this shrinking customer base.
引入建筑物，对他们来说游戏就结束了。是的，新建建筑真的很重要，因为如果我们禁止在新建建筑中使用燃气，这就发出了这是一个日落行业的信号。对于天然气行业来说，非常重要的是它不要重蹈煤炭的覆辙，我们将煤炭视为过去时代的燃料。但如果燃气在新建建筑中被阻断，它发出的正是这个信号。这是一个正在缩小的行业，拥有不断缩小的客户群。
And that worries not just the gas industry, but its investors, banks, it causes a lot bigger problems. And that's why this fight over new construction is really looming over the industry. That this is hugely important for its future. And as a person who covers this, do you expect to see more state or even federal bands on gas stoves?
这不仅让天然气行业感到担忧，也让它的投资者、银行感到担忧，这会导致更大的问题。这就是为什么这场关于新建建筑的斗争在该行业上方若隐若现。这对它的未来至关重要。作为一个报道这个话题的人，你预计会看到更多州级甚至联邦层面的燃气灶禁令吗？
Is this gonna fizzle out the way it did 40 years ago? Or do you expect it to have a little bit more momentum? I definitely think it has more momentum. I think we've passed this turning point here and we're on a clock for addressing climate change here too. So I think the the entire context of this is very different. I would say though that what to expect is is not necessarily just bans. I think this could take a lot of different shapes. I think what the Biden administration's actually focused on is pushing voluntary consumer incentives,
这会像40年前那样不了了之吗？还是你预计它会更有势头？我绝对认为它有更多势头。我认为我们已经在这里通过了这个转折点，而且我们在解决气候变化问题上也面临着时间倒计时。所以我认为这一切的背景是非常不同的。不过我要说的是，可以期待的不一定只是禁令。我认为这可能会采取很多不同的形式。我认为拜登政府真正关注的是推动自愿的消费者激励措施，
so pushing electrification and not mandating it. I think some states were seeing take different approaches. Like I mentioned, maybe we'll see warning labels on gas. It's not a one-size-solution, but I do expect a lot more movement here. Rebecca, thank you so much for talking with us and thanks so much for your reporting. I appreciate it. Thank you. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Jacob Moldinato Medina, edited by Delaney Hall,
也就是推动电气化而不是强制执行。我认为我们看到一些州采取了不同的方法。就像我提到的，也许我们会看到燃气上有警告标签。这不是一个万能的解决方案，但我确实预计这里会有更多的运动。丽贝卡，非常感谢你与我们交谈，也非常感谢你的报道。我很感激。谢谢。《99%隐形》本周由雅各布·莫尔迪纳托·梅迪纳（Jacob Moldinato Medina）制作，德兰尼·霍尔（Delaney Hall）剪辑，
sound mixed by Dara Hirsch, original music by a director of sound Swan Rihau. Kurt Colstad is the digital director of the rest of the team, includes Chris Barube, Christopher Johnson, Jason Dillium, Emmett Fitzgerald, Vivian Leigh, Losh Mbadan, Kelly Prime, Joe Rosenberg, and me Roman Mars. Special thanks this week to Charlie Spatz at the Energy and Policy Institute. The 99% of his below- below goat was created by Stefan Lawrence. We are part of the Stitcher & Serious XM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building.
达拉·赫施（Dara Hirsch）声音混音，原创音乐由声音总监斯旺·里豪（Swan Rihau）制作。库尔特·科尔斯塔德（Kurt Colstad）是数字总监，团队其余成员包括克里斯·巴鲁比（Chris Barube）、克里斯托弗·约翰逊（Christopher Johnson）、杰森·迪利姆（Jason Dillium）、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）、薇薇安·李（Vivian Leigh）、洛什·姆巴丹（Losh Mbadan）、凯利·普莱姆（Kelly Prime）、乔·罗森伯格（Joe Rosenberg）和我罗曼·马尔斯。本周特别感谢能源与政策研究所的查理·斯帕茨（Charlie Spatz）。《99%隐形》是由斯特凡·劳伦斯（Stefan Lawrence）创立的。我们是Stitcher & Sirius XM播客家族的一部分，现在总部设在潘多拉大楼以北六个街区。
In beautiful. Uptown, Oakland, California. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars and the show at 99PI org, or on Instagram, Reddit, and TikTok too. You can find links to other Stitcher shows I love, as well as every past episode of 99PI org. Or on Instagram, Reddit, and TikTok too. You can find links to others to your shows I love, as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. Click, click, click, click, whoosh.
位于加利福尼亚州奥克兰市美丽的住宅区。你可以在Facebook上找到这个节目并参与关于节目的讨论。你可以在Twitter上@我（Roman Mars）和节目（@99PI org），或者在Instagram、Reddit和TikTok上也可以找到。你可以找到我喜欢的其他Stitcher节目的链接，以及99PI.org上99PI的每一期过往节目。或者在Instagram、Reddit和TikTok上也可以找到。你可以找到我喜欢的其他Stitcher节目的链接，以及99PI.org上99PI的每一期过往节目。咔哒，咔哒，咔哒，咔哒，轰。
you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
本集尚无评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可发表评论。